okay so hi everyone I'm Alex and I'm
really you could say a hardcore Haskell
user so here on this slide you see all
the logos of the companies or projects I
work on and essentially all the or most
of the code is basically Haskell or
something related like pure script or
Elm so I really like Haskell and I'm
really lucky that I can actually work in
Haskell in my professional time alright
so let's start out with Haskell I don't
know how many of you are familiar with
Haskell maybe you can quickly show your
hand and how many of you actually wrote
some code more than hello world in
Haskell cool so quite a bit people that
touch nasca all right I have to click
here
alright so Haskell is basically a
functional programming language right
it's it has static typed and with a good
type inference engine it has immutable
data structures green threads and
pattern matching and well often or
mostly it has good performance and so I
just took this example from the Haskell
home page that you can see when you go
to Haskell org just to show you what
Haskell looks like if you're not
familiar with it so here we define a
function called Prime's right and what
it does is in the function we define
another local function called filter
Prime which we give an infinite list
that starts at 2 right so you might ask
infinite lists how is that possible this
program is never going to terminate well
as I said earlier Haskell is a lazy
language so expressions are only
evaluated when you actually need them
right so in this case you can think of
this as a stream of numbers starting at
2 and then the filter prime function
what it does is a pattern matches on the
list right so you write an expression
that says well here is a list and the
list has to have a head and a tail right
so the first element and all the other
elements
and after we pattern matched on on the
list and we take the first element from
the list appended to the result and then
we call filter Prime again and as an
argument you might know this list
comprehension from Python right we pass
all the numbers from the rest of the
list that are not divisible by the
number we just added to the list okay
and remember that this is a stream of
numbers not actually a list that is
materialized as a list so we can
potentially get an infinitive number of
prime numbers and now it's our job in
our application for example to only take
the first 5 or the only the first 10 and
print them on the screen to not get an
infinite loop alright so maybe you would
you will wonder well is that really
useful can you actually write production
code with with with these techniques
right and I I'd say yes it's it's it's
really useful right you can really use
Haskell as a general-purpose programming
language you can do front-end web
development you can do back-end web
development you can do concurrent
parallel programming cluster confucian
and there are a lot of banks that use it
for finance remodeling and the list goes
on so Haskell's not a toy language or a
language that was amended it was
invented in the academics but it's also
very practical to use in day to day work
and there are many examples and we'll
kind of look at these examples that I
discovered in my journey right so to
start we will quickly talk about
learning Haskell because I think this is
a topic that gets talked about a lot
it's basically I found this this graphic
here and that kind of has this comic
like graph what learning Haskell looks
like from to some people and what my
story basically is I did a lot of PHP
and JavaScript development so I had
nothing to do with functional
programming
and I did an internship at this Czech
pet company and that I saw in the first
slide and that we'll also talk about the
product in a bit
and I wrote a JavaScript front-end
component and then they said well a nice
front and a nice component how about you
integrated in our back-end our back in
this by the way written in Haskell and
I'm like mmm ok sounds scary right and
so I was pretty lucky to have an awesome
boss and and he said come on we'll go
and we'll take two days and we'll do a
Haskell bootcamp so I'll sit next to you
we'll do pair crowing and you'll and
when you come out of those two days you
can you know you can contribute to our
Haskell code base no problem
I'm like okay let's get a shot so we sat
there in this Reuben we wrote a part of
the Combinator library and we wrote a
chat
a small TCP chat server client
application together mate mainly him
telling me what to type and I'm a little
bit pretending that I understood
everything and and and we went from
there and at the end of these two days
he was pretty proud of me and was
confident that I could contribute to the
codebase and I wasn't at all but yeah
anyway so I went back the next days and
I started to actually integrate my
JavaScript front-end into the Haskell
back-end to provide the data that was
needed and actually what I did is just I
just brute force the compiler messages
right so anytime I got some message here
right here you can see for example well
type error we expected an INT but
actually we wanted the characters a list
of characters or a string and that at
that point oh no it's the other way
around right and I just you know try to
figure out well what do you have to put
there to make this work and this is the
simple example here I think it's quite
forward what you have to do in some time
it's not but then I had awesome
colleagues I could ask for help what
should I have to put in this hole and if
you're not so lucky to work in a company
like that then you can also ask the
house community which is really really
helpful and in all these situations and
they try to explain it in depth so that
that you understand
and it you can continue riding ask the
hall so the message kind of like is you
shouldn't be really scared to to learn
Haskell I agree when you look at it the
first time you don't understand it at
least I didn't and but you still should
just stick with it and try to to write
code with with the least with the least
features or anything right so don't fall
into this a lot of people when they
learn Haskell they fall into this kind
of hole of trying to understand all the
abstract concepts behind it but for my
personal opinion that's not even
necessary right so what happens is you
start and you define and let's just take
an example here so I define a data type
called option a so it's an optional data
type right it takes an argument that you
might know from Java generics or yeah
typescript generics and it could either
have this value or it's nothing it's
empty right so you define this type and
then you while writing your application
code you discover well you want to write
a function that changes what's inside
this optional value right so you write
this first function that I put on the on
the on the slide next update optional or
update option right so what it does it
it takes a function that takes a value a
transforms it to a value B then an
option of a and gives you back an option
of B and then basically you have to fill
the blanks so the first line I say well
I have the function and I have a value
inside with a pattern matching I
mentioned earlier so what I do is I
apply the function to the argument
inside and return some of that result
right and in the case if it's none the
value that I've tried apply the function
to will I return on again because
there's nothing to do in this case and
you write a lot of code like this and
what happens over time you or your
co-workers or the half community will
tell you we'll look this idea what you
were writing down here is actually can
actually transfer to a abstract concept
called factor right and they show you
this abstract version and you see in the
type signature it's the the the idea is
very similar to what you had with your
option type earlier
so you have some functor f you have a
function from A to B and then you have
an F holding an a holding in an A and
you get back and F holding a B right so
so the ideas is similar and as you
already used these concepts without
knowing them you kind of already have an
intuition of what of what they should do
right and then this makes it really easy
if you start then to read up what the
actual abstract concepts would mean ok
so you know you start kind of like the
other way around you start to do it in
the convention of the way and then you
learn what concept is behind it right ok
so now that I kind of got to know
Haskell and I could got productive let
me talk about the application I meant so
it's check it's it's called check pad
meet and it's basically a like a really
really large Haskell project with a
hundred 1200 modules of Haskell code and
what we do is we bring Hospital medical
data of patients and lab results and
radiology reports to more about devices
like iPads in this example or iPhones or
even in the web browser for doctors in
the hospital and we do a lot of data
integration work and basically this is a
simplified version of a pipeline and I
see the emojis are not working here
anyway and so on the top on the top left
hand side you see the the documents that
come from the hospital right they have
various formats like age level 7 that's
a very clinic specific format DICOM
that's an image exchange format that is
used in hospitals and also XML files and
and these things are imported by one of
our our services right and in this
import step we basically trying to get
rid of all these custom or different
various set of data formats and
normalize it into one single format in
this case XML so the next step is we
interpret this data right so because you
have to
Eric notion of a patient or of a lab
report but every hospital wants it to be
displayed in a different different way
right someone someone that if your lab
value is abnormal they want to be read
others want it to be blue and and stuff
like that so we we do kind of like the
the logic interpretation of the data and
then we write the result again into a
format call to save copy that's Haskell
specific and or known from Haskell
library I will explain and final step is
a synchronizing server that actually
then takes this pre-processed data and
pushes out to all our clients right so
that can be anything from a from a web
front-end to for example iOS device and
then you see the happy user this which
is just this question mark with this
device reading the data and we use
protocol buffers for communication at
that point right so let's just try and
follow the pipeline a little bit so what
we start out with is this 8 7 a message
which I just printed here it's a really
ugly format and in text text-based right
and what you see is it's it's basically
you have you have rows that have an
identifier in the first place and then
you have pipe symbols that you know from
ABC as far as his V or something like
that to separate the fields and then you
have the data of the fields and then
there's also these tilde and these hats
and whatnot to put more structure and
today and in Germany a lot of medical
data is sent around like that and so
what we have to do is we have to parse
this data using Haskell and to
understand it right so what do we do to
to to bring this data to Haskell well we
define data types in Haskell that
represents the structure of these of
these messages right so for example we
have we have to define a top-level data
type called message and that contains
segments right so it's a vector of
segments that's what I said earlier each
line you see and all the way in the top
is called a segment and then the second
has a name that's the first component of
the lime like Emma's age or PID s4
patient identification and and
then these these segments they have
fields right so the next data type is
segments with a name and the contained
fields and then we have the fields now
the fields are a little bit more
complicated I've simplified it a little
bit here for this talk so the field can
either be an empty field right so if
there's just two pipe signs next to each
other there's no value inside so we just
treated as an empty field but you still
need to know that this empty field
exists because as you can tell from the
format above for as you know from CSV
that the position of an element is
actually important right because you
want to later then when you interpret
this data know that in field in segment
number patient identification field
number five is the name of the patient
for example right so then we have a text
field that's just plain text content and
you can also then continue to structure
these fields or and have multiple fields
inside fields something like that and so
we represent this in the last case here
down here was the structured field
option right so now we we have a Haskell
description of the H level seven message
and the next step is to parse it right
so we define a function parse each level
seven that takes a byte string and it
returns either an error because we
couldn't parse it or it returns the
structure message that the the parsed H
levels haven't message
now I all made it the implementation
here but in it's just important to say
that Haskell is a really great language
to write parsers in you have a high
level Combinator library that you can
kind of like compose different parsing
methods and then you still get out a
pretty efficient parser so if you are
interested in that check that out and
Google parsing and Haskell now another
thing that comes up when you do software
development is that you kind of own a
write test that your code is correct
because even though in Haskell you have
a strong type system you can still mess
up your business logic right you can
still I don't know put in plus instead
of a minus sign or instead of in a
parser case you expect a pipe sign and
instead of a plus sign or what
and we also learned this the hard way in
Czech pizza when we started out to to
write the application we didn't have any
unit test at all we thought well a
Haskell type system will do a job of
protecting us and we felt pretty bad and
so now we we we agree that a Haskell
needs unit tests right so and but the
cool thing is that writing new tests in
Haskell is actually really easy because
if you look at the Paris age level 7
function you discover that the type
signature already tells you what you
need to put into the function and what
you will get out of the function right
so we put in any byte string we get out
either an error or the parsed message
right and there's no hidden dependencies
there's this parse H level 7 function
can't read from a database it can't
access global state etc right so when
you write your unit test all you need to
do is well you write parse each level 7
from some string that I just put in
there and you write you have a part s
framework that provides some combinators
your ID should be and well in this case
I provided a value message so I should
get out a valid message with a segment
patient identification and so on right
and if I just put some garbage string
inside
I should get some error right so this is
really nice to to to write unit tests
because you don't need to have some
setup code and some teardown code to
make sure that the database is running
and because you don't see it in the
function but it still accesses the
database etc um so what you get out of
this is kind of like this I would just
for a visualization I put an arrow here
so as I said earlier from byte string
right to this either error message and
now as a lot of recent discussion is
coming up about micro services that you
can to use this function and you can
you're really free where you want to
plug this function right you can just
use this function as I did in the test
code inside your project in your code
freely like that or you can you know
hook it up to a TCP hook it up to a TCP
stream for example right so you just get
raw bytes from your TCP stream you
put them in the function and then you
get a message out and in this case we
would serialize it again and send it as
a bad string or you ride an HTTP JSON
interface that gives you gets in some
wrapped bytes representation in JSON and
returns some some wrapped some
structured the message in this case in
JSON format right and you could also mix
these components and so it's really a
nice way of also thinking that these
pure function are not only easy to test
you can also as you know the
dependencies really easy extract them
and use them in in chunga and chunk them
into individual depending services all
right so the next thing we're going to
look up look at is our hl7 server right
so now we can understand we can parse
each level seven functions to a
structured way now we want to want to do
something with them so we have again
documents from the hospital coming into
our our server and the server will parse
them it will convert them into some
normalized format and for iton into XML
for example and write them to disk so we
can process them later and it also will
reply to the person that sent us the H
level seven message that we received it
and that we understood it right because
it's a least it's a health and medical
data health data so doctors make
decisions on this data so we have to
kind of get some kind of insurance that
the data is actually arrived and
processed correctly and the cool thing
is again and Haskell we can just write
down this pipeline using a library
called conduits a little bit simplify it
here but this is just to get the idea
and you just write down the way you your
data pipeline looks like and and then
you can plug in the functions that I
said earlier right so in this example
here we have a source delivering us byte
strings and so we have a function called
server application it takes an argument
that's a source delivering byte strings
that has a sink that receives byte
strings again and then we can put in a
message function that takes a message
and generates a new message right and it
can also do i/o in this case for writing
the route the receive message to disk
for exam
and now we just ride okay we have the
source we connect our source to our hl7
parser then we map overall the parsed
messages and for example right into disk
generate a response whoo you see realize
this response again we I don't know
print this message through sunblock as
unlock a file and finally we send it
back out right so it's pretty easy to
understand what happens here and it's
very very nice for modeling these kind
of data pipelines right so the next step
here was this import service that takes
these different formats right and now we
have them in XML and what we the problem
we ran into is that well
Hospital data constantly changes right
so for example well now we generate XML
files of a patient but the patient for
example they put in his wrong first name
so the XML file will get updated by a
new age level 7 message that changes the
name right or four-lap reports you get a
lab report there's a lab value and then
before the you know they have some
preliminary analyzes and when the final
analyzes gets out and maybe they add
some recommendations for a doctor so we
don't only have static documents lying
around so these documents also change so
to make sure that we can generate new
new objects that are synchronized to our
end devices we need to kind of like
listen to these changes and then reflect
them you know in the next step of our
pipeline right so for example here we
have two lab values on the right hand
and the left hand side and they will be
used to generate a single lab view right
so just as you can imagine a HTML page
that just established all the values in
a tabular way then we also have a task
number one that you can see at the top
that that goes into there so we may be a
doctor created the task that was
attached to this lab report saying well
please check check this again because
this is not true or this can't be true
or something like that right and then
the next thing that you would imagine if
you think in terms of the UI you would
have an Oh
you of all lab reports so what's the
dependency of this overview well it
needs the two previously generated lab
reports or lab report views right and
then if you think of it in another step
up you have the patient record right so
the patient overview page that will link
to the lab overview right this doesn't
only depend on this but also on the the
patient's base data like the name
because you want to display it all the
way now and at the top and so to keep
track of all this dependencies we wrote
a small framework a haskell framework
where you can sort of define a function
and it looks like you're just reading
this value once and doing some
transformation and returning something
but what happens behind the scenes is
that you can that we also track what you
read and capture this it's a dependency
and every time one of these values
changes we rerun your computation and we
give you and then you can do the
transformation again right so in this
example we have a laboratory report as I
said earlier it takes two arguments a
patient ID and a lab ID and returns a
new lab XML what we do is reload the
patient information age level seven
message we load some lap age level seven
message for this patient and then we
generate this view right and we use the
patient's name to display somewhere in
there and as I said earlier a phone as
these dependencies are both changes then
we this computation will be rerun so
Haskell it's not only great for just you
know visualizing and modeling data data
pipelines you can also abstract a way of
lot of complex ideas that you would
otherwise have to you know write on by
hand and you can hide them and in a nice
way that end users don't have to or
library consumers or developers doesn't
have to consider worried about these
ideas anymore all right
and alas content I would like to
introduce is that once you you wrote
this this binary format or once you
arrive at the final representation you
have to store it before you synchronize
it somewhere and Haskell has a nice
library that I was introduced that cause
it's called safe copy that handles
migrations for you which means that if
you write binary objects and you change
them later in your code you can write a
logic migration in your code and the new
version will automatically read old
versions right so if you read an old
version it will read it in the old
binary format then convert it on logic
level to the new data type you were
working on and you won't notice anything
right so it handles these migrations for
you that's pretty pretty cool thing but
the bad thing about this that I have to
say is that it only works in one way so
only the new server can read old
versions but the old server can treat
new versions that's why it's in the
that's why we can't use it in the final
step of our pipeline okay so that's just
a few examples of how you can use
Haskell too if more efficiently write or
structure your code so let's look at a
building and tooling right so let's
start with libraries so back when we
started in five years ago actually the
ecosystem wasn't that great yet so there
were only a few libraries that were
usable and now and we had to write a lot
of them from scratch but this has really
significantly changed in the last five
years so I think now you can really say
that the library because just missed
pretty mature you can find basically a
library for anything for data processing
for web frameworks you have XML powers
of c of jason libraries so there's a lot
of there's it's pretty what you would
expect from a from a major language but
what we have to say at this point is
that we still lack some very high-level
libraries right so there's not too many
libraries for the sort of problem that
well I want a user management system
that you have from know chess I think
it's called password or something like
that so libraries like in this level
they're not too many of that yet sadly
right and so when you have this
libraries you also need a build tool
that can can build your dependencies and
a problem that occurred in Haskell are
very frequently in large code bases so
we have about 200 direct package
dependencies is that the packages they
want different versions right so in this
case on the left hand side we have a
package a that needs packages B and C
and B and C both need D so this is all
great till the point that you can see
any different versions of of D right and
then you have version constraints and
it's gonna come up with a big mess so
what developed was developed in Haskell
was that they took take snapshots of the
entire Haskell ecosystem that are
consistent with each other which is a
huge huge time saver for us because
before we manually did this kind of
brute force which versions work together
and now there's a service and a tooling
system that that does that for us so
this is solved and but we can't only use
the Haskell build tool we also have to
to to compile I don't know some external
libraries to run our house code or
generate some code so we need a little
build system on top of that right so
basically you could say well just you
know just use make it'll it'll work and
we did actually use make but the problem
is that the build cup process is very
complex and it was a really hard time to
figure out and to make files what
happens because you need to write parses
that extract Haskell dependencies etc
etc and so this nice Haskell library
appeared where you also get a DSL for
describing your build system in Haskell
and it and now we use a shake so that's
the the Haskell library so you it looks
a little bit similar like a Meg file but
it's actually a Haskell DSL that gets
type check and you also describe your
dependencies and it will track for you
and it will allow you to do incremental
builds from for your project right so
another thing you will hit when when
when developing Haskell at least at
large scale the compiler is pretty slow
so it's I think it's comparable to the
Roskam
we already heard about today and the the
the thing is when you develop small
libraries it's not really a big issue
but when you have a large project you
need to start to cache intermediate
compilation results to make sure that
that your compilation is sufficiently
fast the IDE situation is pretty pretty
immature so there are many in editor
plugins and you can work with them and
they work on libraries and on the usual
applications but if you have a large
application like ours these will start
to run into its boundaries and the
refactoring the refactoring helpers that
you were used from for example from
coming from Java or not all the Ariat
like renaming identifiers so there's
still some ongoing work but I think this
maybe if you wait another year or
something this will be solved because
there's a lot of effort put into this at
the moment alright another thing that we
hit again is well as I said earlier
Haskell is lazy and so when you write a
function like this that you know just
counts up in an accumulator
well the counting app isn't directly
evaluated at the moment that you write
accumulator plus one the compiler only
remembers that we should accumulate this
accumulator later on and so you get this
huge stack of of notions that oh yes I
have to accumulate the accumulator at
one point but it's not actually executed
until it's actually needed this value
alright so these issues can be hard to
track down and above you see a memory
graph from one of our production systems
so when you have that then you have to
really be a Haskell or very proficient
with Haskell to know where you're going
but you only hit these when you write a
large code so when you're only writing
small application it shouldn't be a big
problem right so I'm running out of time
so I'm gonna skip over the last
front-end part and just say one thing
just say one more thing so Haskell
doesn't only work in the backend it also
works in the
and this is pretty cool because you can
now share the API between both in and
use the type system to make sure that
they work together right and then you
just compile now your back-end with the
usual hassle compiler and you call the
compile and the API package and you also
compile your front-end package
against this API package and then you
get you know an API for free right so
that's the end of the talk
thanks for listening and I think I can
take one more question thank you